Fox News facility in South Los Angeles
has been evacuated tonight workers
discovered a suspicious package
addressed to congresswoman Maxine Waters
KTTV Fox Los Angeles bill milk Melvin
joins us from outside that complex bill
what do you know yeah Tucker good
evening what we know is very limited so
far but what I can tell you is that
earlier this afternoon our newsroom got
some phone calls from employees here at
this postal facility telling us they
were being evacuated because of a
suspicious package that was found here
that was addressed to Maxine Waters now
let me give you a live look at the scene
right here
LAPD's bomb squad is on scene right here
we understand they have the robot out
and from people watching our chopper
camera I understand some of the bomb
technicians have gone inside to take
x-rays of this device which is still
inside of the building now we've been
talking to some of these employees
leaving the facility some of them are
very confused about what's going on here
some of us some of them are telling us
they weren't evacuated others telling us
they were but they all know that this
package did in fact have Maxine Waters
name on it one telling us that she
believes that the package had very very
similar markings and ID'd stuff on it
just like the other packages that were
found throughout the day now this would
be the second package found today
addressed to Maxine Waters this would be
if it's confirmed that it's some sort of
explosive device this would be I believe
the seventh bomb so right now LAPD bomb
techs on scene here investigating again
a second package addressed to Maxine
Waters here in South LA will send it
back to you guys
Billy appreciate it thank you very much